cette semaine rando pays vous propose de
découvrir la partie haute du ciel de
mafate en empruntant le sentier qui
conduit du col des boeufs jusqu'à marla
au pied du très vite pour votre santé
parcourez nos sentiers
construite au début des années 90 la
route qui mène au col des boeufs devait
être prolongée jusqu'à la nouvelle pour
permettre un accès routiers à mafate
un projet heureusement abandonné pour
l'intégrité du cirque verità port
d'entrée de mafate le col des boeufs a
été taillés à la main par les habitants
du cirque et le nfc le deuxième point de
passage en montagne le plus fréquentées
de l'île après le pas de bellecombe et
pourtant les aménagements font défaut un
projet est en cours avec notamment
l'intégration des conteneurs dans le
paysage et la mise en place de barrières
de protection
c'est ici aussi la fin d'une montée
intimidante pour les moins bons
marcheurs ça c'est un truc qu'on ne
trouve qu'ici moi j'ai jamais vu ça
ailleurs où les gens donc utilisé des
branches soit qu'ils ont coupé eux mêmes
soit qu'ils ont trouvés par terre
et puis bah après il est il et dépose
donc c'est assez étonnant de voir c'est
tata de ce tas de deux bâtons de marche
improvisée le souci c'est ça c'est que
les gens marchent avec un bâton c'est
pas c'est pas un problème en soi ce qui
est gênant c'est que lorsque des ses
bâtons ont été confectionnés avec une
branche qui a été complètement sous
vêtements arrachés sur une sur une
espèce endémique
c'est un peu dommage d'aller d' aller
défoncer des branles verts ou des boîtes
jaunes pour faire un bâton de marche
dans le sens de la descente pas besoin
de bâton les marches bien taillée permet
de vite s'immerger dans la beauté
sauvage de mafate et parfois d'observer
de belles espèces en fleurs comme ce
petit tamarin des hauts
voilà un exemple de ce que le se
montraient tout à l'heure au col avec
les bâtons de marche
donc là on a le l'exemple typique d'un
branle vers une espèce endémique de la
réunion qui a été sauvagement massacrés
pour faire un bâton de marche
il n'y a aucun doute c'est pas pour
autre chose ici par contre nous voyons
des découpes qui sont complètement
propre et sèche ça ce sont des découpes
faite par le wef pour l'entretien du
sentier la première clairière de la
plaine des tamarins est un endroit
agréable où beaucoup en profitent pour
faire une pause
c'est ici que les routes se séparent
l'une vers la nouvelle l'autre
directement vers marc labbé
la traversée de la plaine des tamarins
aux formes torturées par les cyclones
est une véritable plongée dans un autre
monde aux frontières du merveilleux
plus terre à terre les échelles à
pâturages rappelle aussi que l'on peut
croiser des buzz semi sauvage qui
appartiennent aux habitants des îles est
mais qui ne sont plus exploitées ça
m'agace mais à la sortie de la plaine
commence une courte descente de 300
mètres vers la rivière des galets là on
a l'exemple parfait pour pouvoir
expliquer le pourquoi du nom de cet
arbre ce grand à maranello qu'on appelle
ans non sans difficulté siae théophile a
été refait là ça veut dire que les
feuilles sont hétéros filles hétéros
fils ça veut dire qu'elles sont
différentes au stade juvénile et au
stade adulte
elles ont des toutes petites feuilles au
stade juvénile et ses petites feuilles
en fait se transforme en une longue et
grande feuille qui vont donner leurs
feuilles adultes que l'on connaît si
bien sûr tous les grands tamarin des
hauts et on voit en plus ça très très
bien sûr sur cet exemple à ses parfums
pour pour comprendre l'évolution et la
transformation de la feuille
il existe deux variantes pour traverser
la rivière celle de droite est plus
longue mais permet de passer par la
passerelle un groupe d' aventure
après la remontée vers maison laclos
commence le plateau de marla les
élevages de serre
le passage devant l'église puis
l'arrivée au snack matérialise la fin de
notre randonnée
ce que j'aime sur ce sentier c'est la
facilité d'accès déjà ça c'est quelque
chose de très chouettes et ensuite c'est
surtout la beauté du paysage le la vue
sur le gros morne tout le rempart qu'on
a autour avec le
le grand bénare derrière nous c'est
vraiment magnifique
et puis cette traversée de la plaine des
tamarins c'est une des plus belles
forêts tamarins
delisle on a l'impression que cette
forêt elle a une âme elle a un côté
fantomatique qui lui donne un côté
esthétique vraiment hors du commun et
qu'on ne trouve pas ailleurs
c'est une rando qui est accessible à
tout le monde c'est une rando qui est
pas très difficile moi je pense que
chaque personne qui est capable de
marcher sur ses deux jambes
quel que soit son âge peut descendre un
bar là où la nouvelle sans aucun
problème c'est vraiment à santé d'où ce
n'est pas très long et qui vaut le coup
ce qui me déplaît sur ce sentier c'est
que ben comme c'est un sentier qui est
extrêmement fréquentés on y retrouve en
pourcentage un peu plus de deux
personnes qui ont des mauvais gestes qui
vont peut-être laissé un peu de déchet
au sol notamment des déchets verts
pourquoi on jette pas de déchets verts
parce que ça va nourrir les rats on a
une grosse problématique de rahan fort
être essaiera qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
s'attaquent directement aux oiseaux de
forest lawn aux oiseaux endémiques qui
sont des oiseaux tous menacés
d'extinction jeter des déchets verts ça
les aide à proliférer et ça les nourrit
quoi donc forcément on ne lutte pas
contre le contrôleur à angers tension
déchets verts partir